for a president just months from an
election these will have been
uncomfortable scenes tear gas fired as
protesters opposing multiple government
policies clashed with police in the
french capital but streets filled with
tens of thousands of people marching
peacefully will be more worrying still
demonstrations in paris and towns and
cities across the nation to oppose new
covid restrictions emmanuel macron wants
to bar unvaccinated people from spaces
like bars and restaurants evoking fury
we are not agreeing so we are here to
say to our politics not stops it it's
not possible in the world it's crazy
because this new lawyer
is first separate the population
people are angry about life
because they
they feel there's something wrong with
this government
many talked of a new kind of apartheid
being proposed in france and dozens of
mps who support the new legislation have
received death threats
carol bureau bonner has had to clean off
graffiti covering the front of her
constituency office warning her to vote
against the plans she was also sent a
bullet in the post along with a letter
warning the next one would be for her
lots of emails with the title we're
going to kill you
threats of beheadings and being stabbed
they said we're bullet makers and the
next bullet that lands on you will come
from here and then i also received
threats at my home mentioning further
vandalism and then we also received a
bullet in an envelope sent to our home
the issue has divided opinion in a
nation where around 90 percent of people
are vaccinated some marching had been
jabbed but were out to demand liberty
freedom to choose and not to face what
they call discrimination if they
rejected vaccination
many on this march are absolutely
furious about president macron's
language this week when he talked about
how he wanted to make it hard for the
unvaccinated he told the french
newspaper he wanted to kiss them off the
evidence suggests he has succeeded in
doing precisely that
and some in the crowd use macron's own
words to send the gesture right back to
the president if the legislation passes
it will be enforced within days and you
can bet more protests will follow
including at the ballot box come
election time michelle clifford sky news
paris